[Music]
one of the world's biggest traffic jams
isn't on a road or highway it's at the
Panama Canal by the end of August a
backlog of more than 200 ships waited
for weeks to pass through the Waterway
some were stalled for more than 20 days
we handle about 600 billion dollars
worth of merchandise through the Panama
Canal
and this vital trade route is at risk
the cause a historic drought
the delays are Rippling through the
global economy as lower water levels cut
into shipping times and bottom lines
here's how the Panama Canal is adapting
to a drier planet and what those changes
mean for the global Supply chains and
industries that depend on it
[Music]
when the Panama Canal first opened in
1914 it was a game changer for the
shipping industry
connecting the Atlantic and Pacific
for the first time cargo ships could
save about five days traveling between
the Atlantic and Pacific bypassing this
treacherous Journey around the tip of
South America
by connecting two oceans countries with
vast distances between them could now
compete in global trade but as the canal
Runs Out of Water Canal operators like
rigoorte Vasquez are scrambling to
protect the root Vasquez is the head
administrator for the Panama Canal
Authority which maintains and operates
the Waterway we handle about 55 percent
of all containers that go to the United
States from Asia we do that in about 13
000 transits per year in regular times
ships like this one are elevated to
about 85 feet above sea level through a
system of locks and then lowered down on
the other end
every time a ship passes through as much
as 120 million gallons of water are lost
to the Sea that's enough to fill as many
as 244 olympic sized swimming pools
all of that water comes from a system of
freshwater reservoirs and rivers that
depend on rainfall it operates on fresh
water which is a major difference
compared to any other major waterway in
the world we cannot pump water from the
oceans into the lake even though Panama
is the world's fifth rainiest country it
no longer has a steady supply of fresh
water over the last 20 years there is a
downward Trend in water precipitation we
were 89 feet over sea level nowadays we
are 79 feet over sea level so that is a
10 feet reduction on the lake level in a
relatively sizable Lake lower water
levels are a problem for cargo ships
that sometimes carry as many as 16 000
containers at a time
if ships are too heavy they risk getting
trapped in the canal we have to
introduce draft restrictions which
imposes that every vessel has to come
lighter or with less Cargo in order to
sail through the Panama Canal a ship's
draft limit is the minimum depth of
water a vessel can safely navigate this
decides how much cargo a vessel can
carry without getting stuck as drought
conditions worsened over the summer
their Waterway reduced its draft limit
from 50 feet to 44. for a container
vessel on the average every feed of
draft represents about 300 to 350
containers since May large container
vessels like this one have had to reduce
cargo loads by as much as 25 percent
that of course means that we can offer
less capacity to our customers as a
result of this Lars ustigard Nielsen is
the head of customer delivery in the
Americas at Maersk the world's second
largest cargo shipping carrier in terms
of capacity we actually sail extra ships
to fill in the blanks because we lose
this six feet of water we lose an
opportunity to load some cargo
other ship owners are adjusting to the
restrictions by offloading their cargo
onto trains the boxes are unloaded from
ships on one side of the canal moved by
Rail and returned to the vessels before
they continue their Voyage but the
system doesn't work for all cargo ships
if you are a bolt carrier you they can
call grain there is no way to unload so
you have to come light and you come
light from origin then you look for
another border destination to increase
your cargo and then take it to the final
destination in an effort to save even
more water the canal has limited the
amount of vessels that are allowed to
pass through each day but fewer ships
traveling through the canal means longer
wait times and higher tolls shipping
Executives say container vessels now pay
around four hundred thousand dollars to
cross the waterway that includes a
freshwater surcharge of more than 10
percent meaning the lower the water
levels the more shipping companies have
to pay so far what we have tried is to
reduce from 36 transits per day to 32
transits per day so there are a lot less
spaces to have an option for standby
customers of the 30 slots or 32 slots
that we offer about 28 of them are
already booked container ships that are
able to book in advance typically aren't
impacted by these types of bottlenecks
but vessels that aren't on fixed routes
like bulk and gas carriers that move
cargo on short notice face the longest
wait times
the delays for these types of non-booked
vessels increased 280 percent since June
that's according to project 44 a supply
chain visibility platform on top of the
delays bulk carriers are also facing
higher auction fees they are now an
opportunity to go into an auction where
you can basically bid for getting access
to these limited time slots that were
not booked early now those auctions have
gone the highest I have seen and the
highest number we have seen is a level
of nine hundred thousand dollars to make
up for the higher costs ship owners are
charging customers about six hundred
dollars more per cargo container there's
no doubt that the canal is very
important for global trade if the canal
was not there then that would
essentially add more cost it would add
delays disruptions in the Canal's
operations could hurt Southern
Hemisphere exporters and Northern
importers Brazilian meat Chilean wines
and bananas from Ecuador are right
shipped across the canal Copper from
Chile and natural gas from the U.S Gulf
Coast Transit the Waterway too it's also
one of the fastest and least expensive
ways to move grain and other
agricultural Commodities which leave the
port of New Orleans for China
about 73 of all the traffic passing
through the canal is either headed for
or leaving the United States but
shipping Executives say increasing
transit times and costs are leading some
bulk carriers to seek out alternate
routes vessels carrying products to
customers in Asia May sail through the
Suez Canal or around the Cape of Good
Hope adding one to two weeks to the
journey it's basically your products
that's in brake bulk or in in tanka so
this could be oil it could be a natural
gas it could be grain products for now
Maersk and other large container ship
companies have no plans to divert their
core shipments away from Panama still
Executives say it's not off the table if
drought conditions worsen
yes we have a problem we acknowledge
this will impair your operation but in
order to minimize the adverse effect of
it we are providing the information so
you make the best decision based on real
data on real time the Canal's future now
hinges on a two billion dollar plan to
divert as many as four additional Rivers
into the Waterway that's in addition to
the three rivers that already feed it
but adding new reservoirs is a costly
and lengthy undertaking new water would
have to come from watersheds that are
farther from the canal requiring the
construction of tunnels as well as dams
River Divergence also put pressure on
the Region's limited water sources which
Support over 2 million people and the
surrounding rainforest ecosystems
ultimately Canal operators are working
to maintain a balance between the water
needs of the canal the environment and
Panama's growing Urban population we
have to make Provisions to supply fresh
water for water consumption well in
advance economic growth and population
growth there is a slight competition
between water for Transit and water for
human consumption the Panama Canal
Authority is also investing in new
infrastructure outside of the Waterway
we are thinking about roads we are
thinking about storage facilities we are
thinking about complementary services to
be provided for cargos that can wait in
Panama to find the Final Destination
these changes were meant to be carried
out over 25 years but administrators say
drought and changing weather patterns
has cut that timeline down to 10. Canal
operators see this crisis as an
opportunity to fast-track critical
infrastructure build outs the
opportunity is now because there is a
high level of awareness of the situation
people have a sense of what the value of
not having fresh water means
[Music]
foreign